[Music]
my name's Douglas Kim or esophageal au
revoir
I've been working the restaurant
industry for 19 years today I have a
privilege to taste instant rabbits
smells very familiar but it's not in a
good way the color looks very I don't
remember when the last time I actually
had this very very watery flavor was
very very commercial very instant flavor
to be uncertain I don't even know if
this is taste like a chicken or not one
store I respect I know people who
created this ramen that's why giving
one-star already looks a little more
complicated I see the black olive oil
smells a little bit more refined not bad
noodle is a little more skinnier
slightly softer but in a good way
still full of msg flavor very umami but
actually I was pretty surprised
addiction taste not bad I really enjoyed
this one 2.5 star
this one is very familiar actually was
must not a good though
damn spicy oh my god this pretty spicy
is too spicy that I don't use anything
elses nor wise the dishes are so far
best it has aloe vera too - it tastes a
little too spicy for me I have a limit
to take in a certain spice level this
one I give you 2.5 - Wow
he has a more body on the broth noodle
self is a little a lot thicker noodles
very nice I taste a little less msg
broth is more richer is sticking into
the noodles look like a proper ramen
there's pretty good you know quality or
on it it's pretty close - yeah just
regular ramen if you give it to someone
else
you can probably fake it three-star it
smells nice it smells very instant good
smell of msg not bad pretty sweet
actually I like this when I want to went
to a military school almost 20 years ago
I remember Indonesian students always
buy that we swap the noodles very
flavorful is not really pleasant looking
but taste is good noodle texture is good
too flavor is very nice free i'll say
that really liked it yes the noodle in
general is very convenient for many
peoples myself - you know but when you
at least we got a real ramen restaurant
everything comes from scratch and
definitely when you actually eat a fresh
ramen and it's kind of hard to go back
to instant ramen that's why we recommend
you to go to little ramen restaurant and
try real ramen smell is not that spicy
but actually I take it back I get it
each year I know oh my god
[Music]